waylynn are willing wait what that
doesn't even make sense
Carrie Underwood reveals the gender of
her and husband Mike Fisher's baby
during the CMA Awards the cry pretty
singer took the stage Wednesday night in
Nashville alongside friend and fellow
country superstar Brad Paisley for their
11th year in a row hosting the
prestigious awards show and it was
hilarious and you have really let
yourself go
yeah I'm pregnant what what does it
anybody tell me anything when did this
happen here he came to work not only was
her fashion game on point all night with
eight outfit changes her powerful
performance of Love Wins gave us all the
feels and brought the crowd to their
feet
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Carrie also made light of her terrible
fall that happened last year shortly
after the 2017 CMA Awards it is a bubble
wrap dress you really shouldn't have
hey last year I don't know if y'all are
but two days after last year's show she
took a really bad fall so tonight that's
not gonna happen again not on my watch
put this on
gonna win yes come out trust me it looks
great
seriously look at it they look great and
it's fun you get to like pop the little
it's falling and pop these here
speaking of sounding great stomach
breath and to top off the night carry
one female vocalist of the year for
fifth time dominating the CMA category
which brought her to tears this means
[Applause]
[Music]